so Donald Trump did something seemingly
inconceivable during a press briefing
last week he wondered aloud about taking
heat light as well as surface
disinfectants bleach and isopropyl
alcohol and putting them inside the body
to fight coronavirus this was
instantaneously one of the most viral
and sickening moments of trump's
presidency heard around the world I will
get to that part later but I want to be
really clear about this before we move
on I tweeted this over the weekend the
scariest part about the injecting
disinfectants Fiasco isn't that Trump is
so dumb he is he's clueless about
everything medical and many other things
but the real scary part is that Trump
has been briefed by experts for months
about how viruses work about social
distancing about all of the stuff but
he's still imagining that the solution
could be something like injecting bleach
right
something could materialize that would
make all of the briefings and and expert
testimony moot because hey maybe if you
put Lysol in the body we could take care
of his over this thing that's the crisis
that he so misunderstands the problem
that something like that would even
conceivably be the solution he's sitting
around after being told about here's the
timeline for vaccines here's how
therapeutics will be tested here's you
know the are not of a virus determines
how quickly it spreads and here's how
social distance and can affect that
we're developing treatments were clearly
going to surpass the 60,000 a death toll
that that you've been talking about and
he's sitting around thinking you know
maybe we inject the bleach and that
solves the problem that's the scary part
and the entire thing has turned into
such a shameful embarrassment for Trump
that he bailed on taking a single
question during Friday's press briefing
pre things briefings were immediately
announced to be pared down
Axios first reported that there's gonna
be a big cut back on briefings they will
be shorter he may not be taking
questions no briefing on Saturday no
briefing on Sunday some of trumps
closest advisors have apparently
convinced him that the press briefings
are hurting him more than they are
helping him he's overexposed they're a
spectacle and it's really bad which we
knew from day one
the other thing is there is actually not
that much to say each day in the sense
that it's the same lies he says we're
number one in testing
we're actually 41st in per-capita
testing he says our death rate is super
low well actually we have the 16th
highest death rate in the world out of
more than a hundred and eighty countries
with the virus and that's how you end up
rambling and saying something like what
about putting bleach in the body now
notably before going into hiding Trump
did try to argue I said it but it was
sarcastic take a look at this ask you
two questions are casting Li to
reporters like you just to see what
would happen now disinfectant for doing
this maybe on the hands would work and I
was asking the question of the gentleman
who was there yesterday bill because
when they say that something will last
three or four hours or six hours but if
the Sun is out or if they use
disinfectant it goes away less than a
minute did you hear about this yesterday
so before Trump realized that he needs
to stop taking questions or he's going
to be asked about this he tried it was
like a trial balloon tell them it was
sarcasm totally nonsensical first of all
I don't know that Trump really knows
what sarcasm is versus a joke versus a
pun but secondly like what is the joke
what's the punchline what kind of a
sarcastic thing to say is it maybe we
inject disinfectants to see how the
media would rat react so Trump went into
hiding over the weekend he did not take
a break from Twitter though and we're
gonna talk about that a little bit later
spending the weekend in the context of
global shame and I'll show you examples
of that later just rage tweeting about
the media so the big news is Trump spent
the weekend sheltering in place so to
speak from the media even some
right-wing news outlets like the website
Drudge Report mocked him with images of
bleach chewables Neil Cavuto from Fox
News made it clear Trump is lying when
he says it was sarcastic so this is
where we are right now and we will see
what today's press briefing looks like
let's take a quick break let me know
what you expect I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and we'll be right back with much
more I'm really excited that one of our
sponsors
today is helix sleep I sleep on a helix
mattress at home I absolutely love it
and that's why I reached out to them
about sponsoring the David Pakman show
buying a mattress in the past was always
a huge guessing game for me I didn't
know what I actually needed I didn't
know what I would like but helix has a
sleep quiz on their website you tell
them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness I generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress hilux was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both GQ and Wired magazine it
is well deserved I can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty you can try the
mattress risk-free for 100 nights and
they will even come pick it up at your
house if you don't love it but I know
you will all of my viewers will get up
to two hundred dollars off your order
and you'll get two super premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video